To do or to make in Spanish is hacer and it has a silent H.
It's H-A-C-E-R.
So in most of Spain, actually, that would sound acer, but hacer in most of the Spanish-speaking world
What verb type is it?
What is the ending?
Er.
So actually whenever we come across a new verb, we want to make a mental note what is the ending
Or rather than make a mental note, just process it.
Remember we always want to do anything but memorize.
So just looking and going, aser, erverb, okay, just to get in that habit.
If we know it's an adverb, we know how to work with it.
So how would you say he's doing or making, she is doing or making, you are formal doing or making
Ace.
Good.
You're doing it.
Lo hace.
How would you say they're doing it or you guys are doing it?
Los asen.
Lo asen.
Very good.
Are you informal are doing it?
So what is the sound for informal you?
Asin.
So for informal you we add on an S to the Hishi version.
So we get Asis.
Asis.
You're doing it
Lo haces.
Good.
The word for what in Spanish is que.
How do you say what are you doing?
And this is a way of saying how are you as well?
What are you doing?
What are you up to?
Good
So we see that for R verbs we have the principal sound of A, and then we add our N or S, N for they or U plural and S for informal U.
And for er-ir verbs we have the key sound e and we're adding on s for informal you, n for they, you plural.
Now these associations
between s and informal u and n and they or u guides we're gonna see all throughout the Spanish verb structure
So I'm this confuses me a little bit.
Isn't this also a memorization?
Having to remember which ending goes with what
There's a difference between memorization and remembering.
We're gonna remember through not actively trying to memorize
So I'm not telling you you shouldn't remember anything, you need to remember Spanish.
I'm telling you that you're going to remember it much easier without the active process of trying to memorize anything, which blocks whichever processes we need for remembering.
I like to describe it in this way that you borrow information when you memorize it.
But when you are applying it practically in this construction of these sentences, when you are looking from many different angles.
at the elements that we're looking at in Spanish, then you are internalizing it.
Then it's really yours, you're not borrowing it.
Puedo, puedo in Spanish means I can, I am able
Puedo.
Good.
P-U-E-D-O.
Puedo.
You're probably noticing as well that D is quite soft when it comes in the middle of a word in Spanish rather than a hard d
So puedo means I can or I am able and the two form of the verb is an er verb
So puedo is an error verb.
So how would you say he can or she can or it can or you formul can?
Puede.
And how would you say informally you can?
Wear this.
Good.
Now in English we don't say can you to come, but it's what we mean.
Now this is an English problem.
The English is taking the two away here.
It does it sometimes.
You don't say I must to come.
You say I must come.
No?
It's like I am able to come.
You can think of it this way as we thought of I must come as I owe to come.
So how would you say can you come talking informally?
Puedes sorry informar puedes venir.
Puedes venir.
So this is what we're gonna be using to talk with friends.
Not this s we're gonna be hearing it a lot.
If it helps you make the association, you might have heard como estás.
How are you?
The S on the end of estas there is this informal S.
Tuez.
So can't you come?
Why can't you come?
Quiero
Oh to know.
Um okay I'm going know and knowledge and that's not taking me anywhere.
Boys got savvy.
Ah yes.
So I want to know
Quiero saber.
Quiero saber why.
¿Por qué?
You can't come.
No puedes venir.
Very good.
If we address each part part by part and apply all of our mental energy just to the part we need and then forget it.
Quiero saber por qué no puedes venir.
Very good.
So to recap, we have R verbs and we have er ear verbs.
For all of the verbs we take off the ending r, er, ir and we put o for the I version.
So when der is to sell and I sell is
Vendo.
I buy isar is uh to arrive.
Yearo.
Yeah.
Oh, Yeego.
Yeego.
Good.
So with this rule, we can take any verb and we can do this
If it's regular, maybe it's irregular and we try it and we make a mistake.
So for example, salir is to leave or to go out.
If we apply this rule, what are we gonna come up with?
Salo.
Sal.
But it's wrong.
It's salgo.
So it's one of those go instead of oh like bengo I'm coming tengo I have salgo I leave I'm going out
They're quite common verbs.
We tend to find in all languages that the most common verbs are the most irregular.
Esperar, esperar means to wait and to hope.
Which is interesting and it's accurate enough.
I mean you're not doing much more than waiting when you hope.
We have it in the word desperate actually.
This is un and you're hopeless when you're desperate
So esperar is to wait or to hope.
How do you say I'm waiting or I'm hoping or I wait or I hope?
Espero.
Now how do you say he waits?
I'm really glad you made that mistake actually because it's uh it's a wonderful point to elaborate on.
Before we touch a verb, we want to take one split second to go esperar ar verb.
Otherwise, what happens?
Our brain is e from esperar and it wants to put an E.
What your mind is doing there, putting an E because you have S
And when you're adding on suffixes, there's like
two or four, depending on the suffix, two or four different versions of that suffix that you can add on so it can agree with the vowel before.
So there's something in your mind that would prefer an E there.
Of course, because it's S B
And like I said, you even see this formalized in other languages, like in this phenomenon of vowel harmony.
So to stop that process from happening, you must run back to the two-form and then you take control
Espera.
And Espera means he, she, it, you formal, wait, or are waiting, is waiting.
We can build the rest.
So how do you say they wait?
Esperan.
If you want to say they're waiting for me, we don't need the word for for.
It's just like they await me.
We don't need the word for for.
So how do you say they await me?
Esperan me sorry, me esperan.
Me esperan.
The only option though, because it's a changed verb.
They're not waiting for me.
Good, no me speran.
I want to know why they're not waiting for me.
I want to know.
Why
Por qué no me esperan.
Very good.
Quiero saber por qué no me esperan.
Well done.
I was just very happy that I re I remembered Saver.
Finally Saber now with a B.
Saber.
Saver, good
Isn't it from Savi?
Yeah, there is a grey area between V and B.
So it will change between languages.
Actually a very nice example of this is the word for vocabulary.
Vocabulary in Spanish is vocabulario.
Vocabulario.
It's spelled with a V.
But the word for mouth in Spanish is boca, spelt with a B.
Now of course vocabulario is coming from boca.
Your vocabulary is uh your mouth, you leri.
This gives us another rule, actually.
Words ending ere will become ario.
So necessary.
Necessario.
Contrary.
Contrario.
Good